tremendous honor for me to be here
it's logical it's logical to matter it's
logical Tomita and algebra so so that it
wouldn't sound like a company selling
towers and so this talk will be about
some things which involve these three
topics and it will not be about all of
logic it will maybe be all about all
outer matter I mean I mean you won't
learn everything about automata but this
is but I mean certainly will not be
about all about
so in particular here when I say algebra
it would be mainly things like more
notes and maybe universal algebra so
that kind of add but of course the main
point of interest is this red circle
which is you know how they mix up and I
would what I would hope to do in this
talk is to present some many classical
results much of them up to sixty years
old or more than 60 years old and but I
would like you to have a feeling of what
is the kind of topic here and with less
of an emphasis on current research but
just to explain what are the connections
okay so I will start off by explaining
what kind of logic what is the
particular type of logic that this talk
is about so let's go to to logic and so
first and I the first type of example of
logics and this is exactly and
non-examples know what I'm going to be
talking about suppose that you want to
describe the set of graphs which contain
a triangle one way you could do it is
you know for instance you want to you
could write an algorithm which inputs a
graph and you know there's a for a loop
or something and test if it contains a
triangle but another way to do it is to
express this property in the language of
root so I hope this formula is right
it's very difficult to write formulas
which are correct so you would say that
there exists a vertex X exists a vertex
Y and exist a vertex Z such that they
are pairwise connected and therefore
form a triangle so you could write this
in the language of launched now the idea
of using formal logic like quantifiers
and stuff to express properties in
computer science I think it's called
database theory and this has been
tremendously successful I think so I
would guess that I don't know maybe for
Qian has a better idea on the profits
gained by writing formulas like this but
I will you know take a number out of my
finger let's say 60 billion dollars
gained by this idea for no good reason
so it's it's yeah it's it has been
incredibly influential and I as far as I
understand it originated not far from
here that's correct so that's one type
of logical so you use formulas and this
is all the examples are going to be like
this but I would be changing the types
of logics is subtly until I get to the
one that I would actually be talking
about so let's have another property
also of graphs because this is an
intuitive model maybe let's forget that
let's talk about graphs which are 3
colorable so if you naively formalize
the definition of 3 colorability using
logic and you can't do it much better is
you would say this way there exists
three sets of vertices red green and
blue now in my previous example the
quantifiers would range over elements of
the graph so vertices now they range
over sets of elements exist three sets
of vertices and then you say that you
know it's a free coloring so what you
have to say is something like every
vertex has a color so for every vertex X
is either red green
and then you want to say that every Edge
has endpoints with different colors and
you know you write some quantifiers
which say that so that's another example
of a formula this time as you can see
apart from quantifying over elements of
the structures of vertices I can
quantify also over sets so this is
something called higher order logic
second-order logic and this is also this
is a logic that is close to their
interests to the topic of this
particular talk so for example a
classical result is Fagin's theorem
which says that if you managed to
express a property of graphs in a lot
using a formula similar to this one then
it's going to be NP and as if and only
if so what does it say it says that a
property of graphs but it's not really
about graphs it could be a word about
anything is in NP if and only if you can
expand it in something called
existential second order logic so what's
existence to a second order logic it's
formulas like this what does that mean
that means that you first have
quantifiers which are existence or only
but they can range over sets of elements
or you could also have sets of pairs of
elements and so on so you have these are
the so-called second-order quantifies
because they range not over individual
elements but sets of elements possibly
sets of pairs and then inside here you
use only first-order logic which means
you can only quantify over individual
elements but you're allowed to use
negation so for example I don't know the
universal quantifier and you could mix
it in the existence Irwin and stuff like
that so that's this is what's called
existence for second-order logic and it
captures exactly of the class and P so
you could imagine that lady you could
prove that p is equal to naught
and not equal to NP but you know using
this somehow or or not or proved
different things about NP maybe no this
particular one but that has not been
entirely successful ah so that's another
type of flood so you can use basic
first-order logic and you can use
second-order logic but this talk is not
really about that so that's a but it's
close so I am typically going to be in
this talk interested in finite moments
although I will mention anything most at
some point and for example here you will
have things like this is connected to
something called algorithmic methods
theorems and you have theorems which say
that if you can express a property in
some logic then you can do it by an
algorithm or a certain type Fagin's
theorem is an example but you can have
better examples which are actually give
you some insights that maybe would
require some work to prove that
something can be done polynomial time
but just by the very fact that you can
express it in a certain logic that gives
it to you for free but what I'm really
interested in this talk is about logics
like this but not over arbitrary
structures like arbitrary graphs but
over structures in graph structures
which are very structured so things like
words or trees so that would be my third
example let's have it here so suppose
that you want to express trees where
then the vertices are red or black and
you want a property of these trees so
for example describe those trees where
no leaf is colored red okay so since I
assume here that rather black are the
only two available colors I could
they every room every leaf is black so
you can use the formula and the same
spirit as in the previous example so we
could say for every for every node X
which is red so I have a unary predicate
here which I don't know the thread there
is something below it so it's not a leaf
I hope this formula is correct I try to
keep them short and write their natural
language above it so that I'm immune to
errors and these are the type of things
that I will be mainly interested in this
talk
so using logics and I will explain what
kinds of logic to express properties of
words in trees and since / words and
trees you can run out a method and you
can ask about the connection between two
objects automata and that is what I will
be talking about so it's a very classic
theme in the study of logic in computer
science which is the connect which is
words or logics over things like words
and trees and how they connect to
automata and this is what I would like
to talk about ok so that's the type of
logic logical world sees and this is the
topic oh oh my
ok so let's go to the connection with
automata I wanted to introduce an
automat me but I don't think I'll do it
anyway so what's an automaton let's
start off with a basic type of ultimate
an hour an ultimatum over words so if
you haven't seen an automaton here this
is it looks like this I will use the
convention here that red states are
accepting just to keep you awake and you
have an initial state here then you use
it to to read a word
so you input a word and then this device
will just say yes or no and the way it
does so so suppose that your word is
this then what you do is you start in
the initial state at the beginning of
the word and then you ask you know I am
here this is my input letter so what
should I do what this ultimatum says I
should stay here so I I read one input
symbol and I continue to be here then I
ask what should I do here well
do this so it will move here and then
make a self-loop and you know continue
doing so until you reach the end of the
world and in this particular case I end
up in a state which is which is not not
accepting so they were deserted so that
doesn't matter now the beauty of
automata is that you can genders concept
is incredibly robust and you can
generalize it to infinite beings to link
to the trees and also maybe even two
graphs in some cases and it's it's a
it's a very robust console in my talk I
will be mainly talking about finite
words in signing trees okay so that's an
Optima tone and now about the connection
with logic if I want to talk about the
connection with logic then I will state
three very simple observations about
automata and that would be my basis for
making the connection plot so these are
three simple observations about them so
what are two three closure properties of
all regular languages number one if I
have two regular line with languages
then I take the intersection or the
union that is also going to be regular
and the way you can prove it is that
this I will try to entertain you with
animation you haven't seen it before so
this is say one automaton and this is
over one letter alphabet so it just
accepts word which says that the length
is divisible by three and then you have
another item atom such that this is also
or one that your alphabets oh I don't
put labels here this will accept words
such that the length is at least three
and if I want to say there take the
reunion then that would be words which
have lengths divisible by three or have
lengths at least three we'll see what
that gives so the way you do it is you
take a product of these two open so you
take an ultimate answers that the state
of this product ultimate is a pair of
states is going to be a rectangle which
you will look like this and with the
arrows being done in the natural way so
if I'm in a state here then I
I make a step in both ultimate and they
see where I end up and since I'm doing
in this particular case the Union then I
take this and that because it's poor so
that's the construction for taking the
union of two regular proves that if I
have two regular languages and their
union is regular and the same thing
works for intersection that you just
need to to the accepting sentiments
another simple observation is that if
you have a language recognized by now
that and then the complement of that
language so it says swap yes with no
it's also going to be recognized by an
automaton and the way you show it is
that for example if your time Adam
happens to be deterministic as is the
case for this particular picture then
you just complement accepting states
that gives you an which says yes which
switches between yes and no so that's
how you do complementation and then
there's a final construction which I
will call guessing and this is maybe the
most important one and it is at the
following one suppose I have an
automaton here over a two letter alpha
so this automaton I don't know what it
does that some property over words of
words over F with a B now what you could
imagine is that you have a function from
A to B to C where there is only one
possibility for such a function and you
get a word over this alphabet C and now
what you want to know given a word over
the alphabet C is it possible to come
back across this function of this many
different ways because for every
different letter you could choose a or b
so if your word has length and then
there's two to the N possibilities for
that and you want to know given a word
of Rufford C can it be lifted to a word
of length of the idea which is accepted
by this ultimate so that would be the
image of the language recognized by this
automaton under this function and that's
what I would call guessing here and the
way you do it is you use non determinism
now it is my great honor to to have in
the audience
of the person-centred non-determinism
over there Dana Scott so it's another
reason to be stressed about giving this
talk so what what you do is you just
take this exact same ultimatum but to
every label that appears in it you apply
the function f so in this particular
case you will have C's everywhere now
the thing is that this was deterministic
so if you were here any letter you you
you had a letter A or B you would know
exactly which state you would be in but
by up doing this you end up with a
non-deterministic out or nothing because
for example here when you see you could
either do this or do that
but this automaton has the property that
accepts a word if and only if it could
it is the image of some word except
debates that's what I would call
guessing now if we use this guessing
construction then we will transform a
deterministic automaton into one which
is known to ten minutes if we wanted to
use complementation we required a
deterministic ultimate therefore if you
want to do guessing followed by
complementation the obvious way to do it
would be to first introduce non
determinism and then determine eyes
which would result in an exponential
blow-up and this is in general
unavoidable because if you iterate these
things and times they're out of the
automaton might grow up blow up known as
elementary and so these are three basic
properties of regular languages and the
reason why I mention them is that they
look very close to logic so this looks
like the positive boolean connectives
and an or this looks like negation and
this as you will see looks like the same
thing as an existential quantifier which
given the C's guesses the subset of
positions would had a and this
observation that these automata look
like logic is formalized in the world
will be formalized in a moment in a
theorem which I will illustrate first by
an example so let's consider this
formula so it's a formula which inputs a
word
okay and what it's going to say is that
the word has even left and how does this
formula do it well you say that a word
has even length or I think odd length
this is only if there exists a set of
positions in the world which contains
every other position so with the set of
positions alternates between years no
yes no yes no yes no since he says yes
to the first position says no to the
last position
that's a roundabout way of expressing
that the word has odd but what you see
here is that this is expressing the type
of logic that we described before and
actually the logic that you do it in is
called monadic second-order logic so I
will explain now what that means it is a
special case of second-order logic but I
will say so what you're allowed to do is
you can quantify over sets of positions
now remember in second-order logic you
could be out you would be allowed to
quantify over sets of pairs of positions
or sets of triples of positions this is
not the case here that's why it's called
monadic so this means set over of
individual positions as opposed to sets
of care but second-order means you're
allowed to quantify over sets it would
be third order if you would be sets of
sets but that's also not the case okay
the other thing you can do is you can
quantify over individual positions which
i encode by writing this more small case
that there's a big red letters you can
talk about the order of positions
because we're dealing with words and
that implicit that also accounts for
successor which can be defined in terms
of order and in general you can also
talk about labels of positions because
you want to express the property of a
word which might have an alphabet like
ABC so you might want to ask if a
position has labeled a B or C but this
is not witnessed in this particular
example but in general URL to do it you
can talk about labels of course
so that's monadic second order logic a
formula which is built using these
operations and which is used to express
a property of a word such as having odd
lands as in this example okay now
here's the theorem just technically
quite simple but it's I think a very
deep theorem what do you fear although
not you know to prove it it doesn't take
too much time but it's a very influence
the following conditions are equivalent
for a language of finite words it is
recognized by a finite automaton or it
is defined and the equivalent condition
defined by X and the reason for this
that the more interesting part and the
one that I have I think argued here is
that how do you go from a finite
automaton from a formula of monadic
second-order logic to a finite automaton
you use this closure properties because
this corresponds to guessing this
corresponds to intersection then if you
want to have universal quantifiers you
use complementation you get all of the
connectors of the logic so that the
general idea this was a theorem that was
proved originally by independently in
the early 60s I believe by be here
gotten flattened rod which showed that
it's kind of natural because it was it
appeared in three different places at
the same time and it works for other
things as well
now it will work for whatever notion you
have different than finite words so for
example infinite words or trees or
something as long as you can come up
with an automaton module that is closed
under intersection and union
complementation and guessing then this
will work for you so a typical way to do
it is to have automata will have a
non-deterministic and deterministic
automata non determinacy liaos you take
care of that and determines allows take
care of that as long as the tomorrow's
are equivalent then you can alternate
between guessing and complementation so
this theorem has been proved for example
for infinite words infinite words by Big
E so there are this is true also when a
famous result is is by rubbing which
says that this works for infinite trees
also works for finite trees we find a
tree
is not so hard to prove for example for
infinite trees there is no determination
known and that means I mean it's not not
possible in a certain precise sense and
therefore one has to deal with
complementation technically very
interesting construction so there is
also some work by Cassell and others
afterwards for graphs now I would like
to not oversell this because it's
essentially about trees which pretend to
be graphs so it's typically about graphs
of bounded tree weight for graphs of
bounded click with and then it's still
interesting but it really is about trees
somehow so that's that's the field of
that's the automata and logic connection
so the observe ation that formulas of a
certain logic have the exact same power
as as automata and this one corollary of
this and these constructions are effect
if you want to go from an ultimatum to a
logic formula then these are there are
algorithms which do that although
they're not very efficient which is an
understatement
but that gives you for example if you
have a formula monadic second-order
logic and you want to know does there
exist a were a finite word for example
where it's true then you can transform
that formula into no matter on which
takes an incredible amount of time but
finite time and then you can ask if that
ultimate an is empty which does not take
so much time that's the automatic but
what I'm mainly interested what I would
mainly like to tell you about in this
particular talk is the connection of
algebra so algebraic automata theory so
the idea is instead of using automata
use algebra and I will try to argue that
this is a this leads to two
justing insights again most of these
ideas have been around for quite some
time but there is some steady progress
and at the end I hope to let these
people some results are less than 50
years old so algebra
let's in my presentation of algebra I
would like to focus on the notion of a
compositional the reason I do it instead
of amyloid which will appear eventually
this is a way of presenting monolith is
that this in my opinion is more robust
and it extends to different setting than
finite words and so so let me define a
compositional functions what's a
composite a function composition of
function a candidate for a composition
function is something which inputs words
and produces elements from some set now
this is not the only notion of
compositionality result this is
compositional function from words to
something you could have composition or
functions from trees to something you
could have compositional functions from
the syntax of a programming language to
something and so on this is just one
type of compositionality and let me
define it this way so the slogan is that
the function is compositional if the
value of the function on a bigger part
is determined by the values of the
function on smaller parts that's a
slogan so let me make this slogan
precise as follows so suppose I have one
part a word let's say that this word is
called beginning okay and then I have
another part which is a second word and
this one happens to have three letters
and B the word end okay now what I could
do is I could first combine these two
parts into a bigger word that's though
this is the call and these are the parts
and then apply the function another
thing that I could do is I could apply
the function to the parts okay
getting some element of the second
so now I have the ingredients for this
slogan I have the value on the call and
I have the values on the parts and now I
can say that this can be uniquely
determined from this and that and what
that means is that there's a function
this is a two argument operation it
inputs two arguments this and that and
produces that which makes that would be
compositional if you can manage to find
something which does that so the red
arrows technically speaking there are
some operation which take the value on
the first part of the value in the
second part and they sell you what is
going to be the value on the entire
thing so that's what I would define to
be a composition or function and it so
happens that such a composition or
function will turn em into something
called amyloid so those of you have seen
it this is this is this is true I mean
as long as the function f was certain
and it's also going to turn the original
function into a homomorphism and
actually homomorphisms from this to a
mondo it done actually tsukuba anymore
like this well are the same thing as
composition of functions the way they
find this way so if you don't like talk
about mahmud you can use compositional
function the same kind of so that's a
compositional focused and a Konami and a
very important example of a
compositional function and this will
explain the city
I hope explain the significance of
monadic second-order logic is the
following function so let's fix some K
did the idea if this is going to be the
quantifier rank I will explain in a
second well I will explain right now the
quantifier rank of a formula if you view
a formula as a tree where the syntax
tree then the quantifier rank is the
greatest number of quantifiers you see
on any path so fix some quantifier rank
and then it turns out that the following
function is compositional I input a word
and then I map this word to the
sentences of mahalik second-order logic
which are true in that word restricted
to quantify run decay that's a function
it assigns to every word a certain set
of sentences
in general infinite because you can you
know write the same sentence of
quantifier rank K in any many different
ways but one can show is that there's
actually finitely many possible values
this is not very it's a good thing to do
has been known for quite some but
there's there's finitely many possible
values and as the theorem says this is a
compositional function and therefore as
I mentioned composition of functions are
the same thing as homomorphism tamaño it
so actually what we're dealing with here
is a monochrome amorphous term or word
to this kind of moment which happens to
be a finite one so this theorem is
essentially the bahih draftin grodd
i'll-- got theorem because it tells you
that finite mono is a monadic second
order logic well at least it gives you
the interesting direction go from from
monadic second order logic to a finite
mono and i would like to argue in this
particular case to what is the
significance of monadic second
derivative so here's a sketch of a proof
for this theorem and it's just like one
thing that it's a sketch so the open key
observation is that if you have a sub
formula menelik ii or logic what it
doesn't you know with guesses
existentially quantified over a set so
you know but we want to show that it's
compositional so maybe this word is
composed into the first half and the
second half now the key observation is
that a set here choosing a set here is
the same thing as choosing what the set
is restricted to here under set
restricted to here so sort of like
nicely decomposes so if I want to say to
the set here all I have to say the same
thing as saying what is the part on the
right side what is the part of me left
side now the reason why I say this is
that you will see here that this is true
for a set of positions but it's not true
for a set of pairs of positions because
if you want to choose a set of pairs of
positions in a word then it's not enough
to say what is that set of pairs
restrict to the first half and what is
that set of pairs restricted to the
second half because you're ignoring the
information about pairs which live
between here and
that's why the theorem will not work for
second-order logic the general
second-order logic as opposed to
magnetic second so this is this is the
the algebraic view on logic and you can
sum it up in the following theorem that
for every letter language being
recognized by finite automaton being
defined about by a monadic second-order
logic are the same thing this we have
seen already and now we can add a third
condition which says that you're
recognized by a whole morphism into a
finite ma note and this is the
essentially the proof is here because
this is the coma morphine's that you
need if you want to recognize a property
which has quantify rank okay the reason
why I tried to restate this theorem let
me forget that okay let me explain I'd
maybe I didn't say exactly what it means
to recognize a recognizer language by a
homomorphism but that means that if I
want to recognize that language by horse
it means there's a following thing I
have the language which I can view as a
function didn't post a word and says yes
or no and then I will say that a
homomorphism eise's it if it has more
than enough information to say yes or no
and what that technically means is that
you can choose an accepting set so a
function which which inputs an element
of c'mon I can say this or not
now the reason why I stated this theorem
is that if we now now we can use
algebraic properties of mono it to to
describe other logics
so here is that what I think is maybe my
own personal favorite theorem let's
forget this which is the following
let's ask the following question in this
theorem I discussed monadic second-order
logic so no notic second-order logic you
can quantify over sets of positions
what if you consider a weaker logic
called first-order logic when you can
only vial quantify over individual
positions what is the expressive power
of that and here's a very beautiful
theorem which says that for a language L
being definable first-order logic that
is using only quantification over
individual position positions is exactly
the same thing here in general for MSO
monadic second-order logic you use an
arbitrary finite monoid but if you want
to correspond to first-order logic then
you have to use a group free finite
monoid and that what that means is that
a finite monad which does not contain
any subset which is isomorphic to the
group does not need to have the same
identity as the moment and this is I
think you be the judge but I think it's
a remarkable theorem because it connects
two very natural concepts which do not
seem to be related at all at first sight
but yeah so that would be one motivation
to use our algebra instead of automata
because in moments you have a lot of you
know algebraic notions that you exploit
the notions of a group and so on which
are less visible in an ultimatum
I will continue discussing this right
now and well let me ask the question
what is the advantage what do you gain
by using more names develop them so one
advantage we had was this written better
theorem which use groups to characterize
first-order logic and in that direction
you can make the following observation
here the main reason I think to use
moment is that unlike automata finite
infinite monoids have a structures here
if you have an automaton there's not
really too much structure that you can
it's essentially a graph there's not
much structure and there is some that
you can you know decompose it into
connected components or something but
there's not much that is known to be
doable however for a finite monoid it's
it you can do much more so I will
mention a theorem a Berkley theorem by
Kronos which says the following thing as
an example of structures here is finding
quality every finite mono it can be
decomposed into a product of monoid so
that every element of this product is
either a finite group and finite groups
are classified or it is one fixed non
group mono it it has three elements it's
called u2 and it's corresponds to words
that end with a over two letters a and B
so so what this theorem says is that you
have either groups or really nothing
months now I would have to say exactly
what it means to what this product
operation is this is something called
the wreath product is the idea is that
like one mono it reads the results of a
previous ma night and what it does it
mean to decompose and what that means is
that every model is the homomorphic
image of a sub more light of that but
this theorem it really gives you quite a
lot of insight into the structure of any
moment and that's that's very nice and
you cannot really do that with without
automata because there's no structure or
decompositions for out da matta as i
said no no really useful ones I will
give you another example of structures
humanoids with a slight connection to
algorithms
the following slide so to inspire it
let's consider the following naive data
structure suppose that we want to check
if a word has an even number of X the
data structure I will use is maybe help
the smartest data structure to do it but
it's supposed to you know motivate the
later ones and well this corresponds so
here's a word and you know I want to see
if has an even number of A's in this
particular case it has three a so the
answer's no what this corresponds to is
that I have a homomorphism from all
possible words to the two element
additive field now one other thing I
could do a very naive data structure is
the following thing so I first compute
the value of this homomorphism for every
individual letter so A's are one and
these are zero because here there's an
odd number of A's and here there's an
even because there's noise and now I can
just do divide and conquer so I can
group it you know into exponential way
so I group it here then I can multiply 1
0 I'll add 1 means you don't get 1 and
so on and then I can continue doing so
tree of logarithmic depth so that's a
very naive data structure to do that and
for example one advantage of this data
structure is that if I for example
change the label here then I don't need
to modify too many things because I just
need to propagate to change the values
number of teams so this data nice data
structure is supposed to be an
inspiration for something which is more
fancy and uses the structural theory of
moments namely this tree has logarithmic
depth which is okay but it's not
constant now what you can do is you can
have in a certain sense constant depth
so I would explain this in a moment
so I start out the same way as
previously so I have for every position
its value all right I will use example
of the two elements
and now I can combine things now there's
going to be two rules for combining
things rule number one is I can combine
two things that's that's the rule I had
previously and well if you only have
that rule then you're going to
necessarily need a logarithmic number of
steps it's not going to be constant but
there's another rule which says if I
have several consecutive elements which
all happen to have the same data value
then I can combine them together in one
step so I have arbitrary fan in here not
necessarily - as long as all of my
results have exact same value which in
this example is U and to evaluate that
you don't need too much time because you
just need to know what is that value and
how many there are and then you just
that's all the information you need and
these are the only two rules we have so
I can combine two things or I can
combine an arbitrary number of things as
long as they're consecutive and they
have the same time so I could continue
now I think here I will do the binary
rule I combine two different things and
now what I have is I look at the things
which are left and they all happen to
have the same value 1 so I can combine
all together in one step so having these
two possible rules in principle I could
have much shallower trees because I can
have a lot of things like this and it is
indeed the case so there's a theorem of
irrational which says that you can
always find such a tree with depth which
is three times the size of the moment
now that the length of the word does not
appear here so in that sense it's
constant depth you can argue about you
know what are the benefits of that I
mean you know maybe log of any number is
at most 50 anyway so and mono is of size
such that of size 50 over 3 are small
moments but but it is I think of
theoretical interest and to prove this
you really need to go into the
structural theory of montage and how
they're they're ideal structure and
stuff
so one example application of this
result is something that we prove
together with Paro Paris that a logical
x5 which is used in XML this is a it's a
query language which is used to describe
properties of XML files such as web
pages and it's an important component of
it is a component of every browser and
then the previously known algorithm
would run in same quadratic time and now
you can improve this to to linear time
in the size of the document by using
this constant there's other applications
of that so these are the advantages of
using algebra instead of automata
because you have a certain structural
theory that you can exploit and
therefore if you want a take-home
message if at some point you end up
dealing the property of words then I
recommend to that you try to see if you
can abstract it away as a property of
mono it's using a compositional function
which is very often the case and then
hope to use for example this theorem by
Shimon which which is I think in many
cases is a helpful thing the last thing
that I would want to talk about in my
talk is algebra for trees so so far it
was about words and now the last example
I would try to use is of trees so the
first the question is you know what's an
algebra fruit trees what's algebraic
structure that corresponds to monix now
there's a lot of different candidates
and each one half of them has their
particular virtues the one that I will
focus on here is an algebraic structure
called an algebra which is their the
most classical one available so let me
explain this in a moment so suppose that
we have an alphabet now if we're talking
about trees every letter has an air
so this is a you could do it different
ways but this is one way to do it also
known as a signature so we have a letter
of Verity to a letter Verity one and a
lateral a constant and now you construct
trees from that so we'll never use a you
have to have two children also called
Turner's and now that that would be what
our tree is now trees or turns have a
natural algebraic structure in the
following sense so let's use this
definition from universal algebra which
says that an algebra period at the end
of the name is a set with some
operations that's that's extremely
general and simple definition now one
will expect not to get anything out of a
different definition as general as this
but at the last slide I would try to
argue that you can get something about
okay so you just have a set with some
operations by an operation I mean like
for example a binary operation which
takes two elements from here and
produces one element from here or a
ternary operation which takes three
elements from here and this is one
element or a zero Araucana operation
which is a constant that's it that's
what I mean by operations okay now for
example the set of all trees over for
example this alphabet can be viewed as
an algebra the set is the trees and you
have a binary operation a which inputs
two trees introduces a bigger tree by
combining them you have a unary
operation B which inputs one tree on
attaches B to the top and you have a
constant C which is produces this table
tree it's a natural way to do it as a
another brand then what you could do is
you could use a homomorphism of algebra
so what is that so a homomorphism of
algebras is where each algebra has to
source is the underlying set and the
operations here the underlying set and
the operation and
would expect it to be so you map every
element from here to some elements here
a new map every operation here to some
operation here with the same arity in a
way which is consistent so but if you
first apply it here and then apply an
operation over there the same thing as
you apply the operation here and then
went there so that's a brass and then we
could define a regular language of trees
and this coincide with what people
typically call regular language of trees
to be anything that's recognized by a
hormone more sinister that this algebra
is finite so the universe is fine this
is the notion of regular tree language
it corresponds to it extends regularity
from words to trees now what I wanted to
say is this if you have a definition
like this you would say others is
ridiculous I mean you can't you can't
get anything out of it I mean on this
level of generality you cannot really
prove anything and this is not the case
so it so happens that even on this level
of generality
you can have non-trivial structural
theorems and I would like to mention one
of them and that would be the end of my
talk so let me mention the structures
here so which will sort of indicate a
positive answer to this question this is
not something that I'm very well
familiar with but a little bit but I
hope in sufficiently to explain what's
going on so - it is - to illustrate the
definitions in this structural theorem
consider this example suppose we have a
one-hour jabrai which is the Twellman
ballina the rest of the set is 0-1 and
you have the three boolean operations as
another example of an algebra or you can
have the same underlying set yes or no
plus the NAND operation and I looked up
on the internet that you're supposed to
draw it like this and this is well known
that the NAND operation is complete so
you can express all of these things
using NAND and likewise well this is
also complete you can stress not using
these things and that's right what
mean so for example if you want to do
negation then you write a little nand of
X with a 1 I hope this is the correct
thing and if you want to do and then you
just do not and then you negate it and
you know if you want to do
nouns then you just make the definition
the reason why I wrote out this is to
illustrate the definition of a
polynomial so in universal algebra a
little tree like this is called a
polynomial so a polynomial in this case
this is a polynomial over that algebra
is a little tree which uses the
operations from the algebra it uses
variables and is allowed to use any
constant use okay so you any element
from the underlying set as a constant
that's a polynomial in general this is
not maybe visible in my picture you can
use variables several times or 0 times
as well that's a polynomial so what we
have shown is that every operation here
can be expressed by a polynomial here
and converts them so every operation
here 1 can be expressed by a full
movement here and that is the name that
is what we call to algebra the
polynomial it would that's the
definition to algebra so polynomial
equivalent if every operation and 1 can
be expressed via pranaam polynomial and
the other and contrasty so in other
words the polynomials in algebra are
exactly the same so in particular for
this to happen you have the exact same
universe
so that's polynomial equivalence now
here's the theorem which was proved by
pallfy and i think it's crazy so suppose
that you have a finite algebra now this
is not it does not apply to any finite
algebra need to satisfy certain property
i would like i will try to mend talk
about a bit about this property in a
second
which says that every unit unary
polynomial so it's a foreign normal
which takes only one variable X maybe
uses it several times and combines it
with
happens so if you have a unary
polynomial that gives you a function
from the universe of the algebra to the
universe of the other and properties the
assumption is a serum that every unary
polynomial either Maps everybody to a
single element or is a permutation of
you you might think well no algebras
satisfy this property I'll get to that
now if you believed me for a moment that
this is a reasonable assumption then the
conclusion is extremely beautiful
because the conclusion says that every
year algebra like this is polynomially
equivalent to one of the following
things number one the boolean algebra so
if it number to the bully the positive
blue the monotone opposites
number three narrow in monotone
operation the tongue intercepts now this
is up to isomorphous so if you have only
Union then your polynomial equivalent to
this by just taking the isomorphism it
went 0 to 1 okay so these are three
examples and it's words already we've
already done 60 percent so another one
is this a finite vector space over a
finite field what does that mean so
suppose you have a finite vector space
over a finite field you can view it as
an algebra in the following way the
elements of the algebra the universe is
the vector space you have one binary
operation plus as in a vector space for
adding vectors and for every element of
the finite field you have one operation
multiplied by me okay that's the
multiplication by scalars that's how you
view finite vector space over a binary
field as inaudible then you can get this
as a result and the one last thing that
you're left with is a group acting on a
finite set so this is an algebra which
is obtained you take a group which acts
on a finite set and you view it as an
algebra in the sense that the universe
of the algebra is this finite set being
acted upon and
and you have just unary operations
nothing else which corresponds to this
group and then yeah that's do anything
yes so here you don't have any
operations which which depend on more
than one coordinate and now the theorem
says that these are the only things that
you so you have only five possibilities
and there's even universal algebra is
the classical numbering I don't know why
this one but it's they always say
algebra number three or typing before
you have to and that's the theory
that's the end of this year so it says
that assuming this star thing then you
have this this is a non-trivial theorem
it's not not not so easy to prove in
fact somehow the pure results it's no
idea where this I where this came from
and it's like pages and pages of
completely arbitrary decisions which end
up with something like this now I would
like to comment about this and I I said
that it looks like a ridiculous
assumption and don't take my word for it
take policy's word for it because I mean
I talked to him I said crazy theorem
because yeah I mean he says that when he
started to work on this his colleague
paddle to black told him to to to to try
to classify algebras which satisfy
property sorry he said but this property
doesn't make any sense but you know I I
I tried to do it anyway because put that
told me to do it and when he did it but
what turns out later in later
developments this is a dessert I think
Berkeley developments it turns out that
property star is kind of important so in
something that this this serum I would
say I guess is the point or something
called ten congruence here which is a
structural theory of finite algebra
which was developed in by mainly by
McKenzie in the 80s which classifies all
finite algebra in a certain way mainly
the congruence is in demand but it's it
it says has something to say about every
algebra and what they show is and in the
beginning of this is that if you take an
algebra finite algebra and then you take
to congruence is in it and there in a
neighboring conference congressman
there's nothing in between them so every
since it's a finite algebra every two
congruence this can be no connected by a
stain of neighboring ones then to such a
pair of neighboring congruences you can
uniquely associate an algebra and in a
natural and canonical way which
satisfies property star and to that
algebra you can apply the policy theorem
and therefore associate to it one of
these numbers one two three four five
and that gives you a quite a lot of
information and this year and this
theory ten congruent theory based on
this has been for example instrumental
in recent progress on classifying
constraint satisfaction problems so
which may be even possibly it has
already been solved using methods like
this so what I wanted to say in this
example is that even for arbitrary
algebras there is a structural theory
and you can try to use it to get some
benefit from that so I think that's all
I wanted to say so my message is that
often instead of if you have logic and
you want to use automata sometimes it's
a good idea
instead of using automata to use algebra
because there you have a richer
structure or theory and that allows you
to make some maybe interesting
observations so that's that's the
[Applause]
yes
so up twice a month so the the first
thing that you do in the parity theorem
we say maybe the universe has two
elements and there it's not so difficult
to prove that you have five possible
cases or six I don't remember three of
them on that list then it gets
interesting because what you show is
that it has more than two elements then
you necessarily end up in one of these
two cases of vector spaces and and group
actions and that's where the non trivial
matter
I'm not sure I think that's a very very
interesting question I think I'm not
currently aware of such things but I do
think that what you can get is
inspirations for a troll so end up
discovering maybe not proving but
discovering concepts in algebra
motivated by logic and there are
examples of that so there are products
product operations in algebra that are
inspired by connectives in logic for
example so that's as you have transfer
in the other way
[Applause]